alors qu'il servait dans les Forces
Spéciales Benoît Sand 27 ans a arrêté sa
carrière militaire pour porter les
couleurs de la France dans le MMA un
parcours fulgurant en seulement quelques
années qui pourrait faire de lui l'un
des meilleurs combattants de sa
catégorieeno lui vient des forces
spéciales né en 1995 dans une famille de
militaire àim il s'engage à 18 ans au
premier régiment de parachutistes
d'infanterie de marine et passe 4 ans
dans les sables du Sahel entre
élimination de chefs djihadistes et
destruction de Ch d'arme benoî s est
décoré à la fois de la médaille de
reconnaissance de la nation et de la
Croix du combattant c'est en 2017 à
Bayon qu'il se perfectionne en boxe et
en juujitsu brésilien très vite repéré
par son entraîneur il est envoyé en
compétition dans le MMA se réunissent
des champions venus du judo de la boxe
anglaise du kickboxing du juuditsu
Brésilien ou encore du karaté dans une
cage il faut être discipliné dans la
tempête prendre des décisions très
rapides on peut avoir le même niveau
d'adrénaline que sous le feu Benoît s
rafle un titre de champion de France au
bout de 2 ans de pratique et aujourd'hui
il est surnommé God of War dieu de la
guerre il combat en poids léger la
catégorie la plus cauchemardesque en
terme de niveau mais il vint aisément
tout ce qui se présente devant lui
France ma France très
belle pour toi je ferai
bataille je quitterai vers
m sans espoir de les revoir
[Musique]
jamais
lui qui est un fervant chrétien apprécie
se plonger dans la pensée de Pascal et
n'a jamais caché son amour des grands
héros français le capitaine Danjou
Napoléon ou encore Jean d'c qu'il s'est
fait tatouer sur le dos après le premier
combat du FC à Paris ceux qui ont servi
la France dans les périodes de tempête
ont marqué l'histoire par des valeurs
simples et puissantes simple et puissant
c'est le style
[Musique]
BSD